[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained
uh tonight by ben simon's count on our
youtube title
is part 8 of the f3 nimzo and it is
going to be the finale tonight if we get
through everything i want to get through
um so what's left well we've covered
most of
pretty much everything in the f3 nimzo
and uh what's left is pretty much
uh some sidelines that i think are very
much worth knowing that will show up in
your games
uh these are lines that maybe aren't
even the greatest for black
uh at the objective level but they are
natural ways to play
and you definitely will face these
sometimes in your own games
and then if we get through all of that i
wanted to share one or two of my
favorite games in the f3 nimso that
really highlight why the opening is so
good
for uh for white so let's jump right
into it here uh to start with i have a
game between uh timothev
and tarlov in some russian open
tournament i believe
uh and this game starts of course in rf3
nimzo
uh here after f3 and now the sideline
that i want to talk about is actually
here on move 4 the move knight c6 this
is something
that is quite rare but does
have a little bit of bite to it there is
an idea with the move of knight c6
of course in previous lectures we've
covered all the nuances
after d5 the various plans there the
various ideas with the move c5 and the
flexible
kingside castles and so knight c6 is
definitely
a change from those moves that we have
we have been covering so what is the
idea of knight c6
well in a sense it's like the move c5 in
that it's fighting for the dark squares
in the center of the board
quite early on but of course it's not c5
it's just a knight attacking the central
squares which can be a little bit less
threatening
than the pawn itself right the knight's
never really threatening to take here
so long as we have that square covered
enough times
so because of that because c5 is a much
more
immediate threat than knight c6 white is
actually just able to continue with the
move e4 here
uh no reason to not play our planned
idea
of e4 black has really not done enough
to stop it with this move of knight c6
it increases the central pressure but
not to the point where white needs to be
worried
and deviate from our idea of e4
and from here black has two ways of
playing number one is to go with
d5 and transpose into some of those
structures
and the other idea is to play e5 and now
i'm going to start with e5
because i think it's the most in line
actually with the knight c6 idea
it now continues the fight for the dark
squares and i think it's the most
testing but we'll look at
d5 after this game and here white has
two different options and i definitely
prefer one over the other
one option for white is to sort of
relent to black's pressure in the center
and play the move d5 but i think this is
sort of giving black
uh what he wants out of the opening uh
now black can sink this knight on d4
and i think this is essentially the the
whole point of putting this knight on c6
it was to play e5 and get a knight into
the d4 square
something that definitely wouldn't be
possible in the comparable c5 line
when white is going to play d5 right
away and there's never any chance to
play
the knight out to c6 so that's the idea
of this little nuance here with knight
c6 and e5
but fortunately white has a pretty easy
way to deal with this
and that's to simply play the move a3
black doesn't really have a good
response to this move
no matter what probably best is to
simply capture
on c3 here but now white is going to be
able to reinforce this center
and after d6 we're going to get
positions that
you likely are familiar with from
previous lectures
where black goes for this sort of d6 e5
dark squared setup
but it is sort of a little bit awkward
that this knight is standing in front of
this pawn for the moment
and it's just not the most sensible
setup for black
uh that being said i did want to show
how this game could continue
because it was a very nice game by
timothev and it really does show why
this setup is is maybe not the greatest
for black with this knight on c6 so
the game did continue with bishop e3 the
this is the most natural developing move
in my opinion
no needs no need to bring this bishop
out to g5 it does well on e3 supporting
the center
pressuring the king's side and the the
added defense
to d4 is definitely going to be very
relevant here
now we see knight d7 by uh timothev's
opponent
and this is a little bit of a strange
move but it does give this f pawn
some mobility and it begins walking this
knight
over to other squares perhaps back to f8
in some instances and over to f4
now timofev just continues with bishop
d3
and you can really see why this setup
isn't great by black it just doesn't put
enough pressure
on white's center right this knight and
this e pawn together just aren't enough
to make any meaningful threats on the d4
pawn
this bishop alone is enough to defend it
and then white has no problems
developing very naturally with bishop d3
and if you think back to previous
lectures if you have watched them all
in situations like this where white is
able to develop with bishop d3
in this sort of structure without
fearing for the d4 pawn safety
white does tend to be a little bit
better in the game
tar love continues with knight a5 trying
to go for this plan
of putting pressure on white's queen
side deficiencies
and now the simplest is to do what
timothev did in the game
and that's just breakthrough with f4 uh
black's setup is so much worse
comparatively to similar positions that
white can actually just break with f4
directly here
in previous instances we've seen similar
structures where white has to work a
little bit harder to play the move f4
but in this case black is sort of just
stepping on his own toes with these
knights
and timothev is correct in just
immediately breaking with this move of
f4
that being said it doesn't really make
an immediate threat white isn't
immediately looking to capture on e5 or
immediately play e5
it's just opening up this diagonal
increasing the pressure here
and passing the turn back to to black so
tarlov does continue now with b6 and
this is a plan we've seen before by
black attacking the c4 pawn
but white has nothing to fear here
natural development now with knight f3
bishop a6 is easily parried by queen e2
defending the c4 pawn
and now black's play is just too slow in
comparison to whites we see king side
castles
and now a difference between previous
variations
and most of the variations that we've
looked at here black has in fact castled
king's side
but due to the move order black has the
option to castle a queen side but
this change in king location
is actually very debatable whether or
not it actually
favors black the queen side is
definitely not the safest place in the
world for this king either
and white has you know many many paths
to an advantage here
one of which is to just take on e5 open
up the f file
and maybe a more direct way is what
timothy have chose to do in the game
with the move c5
opening up this diagonal and ready to
open up files in front of this black
king
this game continued with takes on d3
takes on d3
and black tries to capture on c5 to keep
things a bit more closed
and now after queen a6 check king b8
f takes e5 uh white now has three pawns
to zero
which is a bigger central advantage than
most people can ever hope to achieve
and white is just significantly
significantly better
uh i will eventually show you the the
rest of this game because i think it is
sort of nice but um this is where i
think uh
the the openings uh are really decided
this is well out of opening now
well into the middle game and it's very
very clear that it's white who's on the
better side
with the central control the safer king
black's pieces are you know in a sense a
bit misplaced
and really no problems at all for white
here but
i want to open up to questions for the
chat room this is the first time we're
looking at this knight c6 move
is anybody confused about these ideas
does anybody not remember
what we're doing in these types of
structures this f4 break i know is
critical
so so questions and confusion in the
chat what do you guys have for me
so yeah if you're watching live feel
free to ask me any questions and then
it will be recorded and saved on the
channel
forever and ever and ever
alright well then let me review this
really quickly and i i will go on to
show you some more of the game
but just to review how we got here
what were the other moves instead of
knight c6 well the first seven lectures
were about d5 c5 and kingside castles
so now we're we're just focusing in on
knight c6
okay so how did we get here so knight c6
the idea being
to apply some pressure to these dark
squares but it's not as severe as c5
so white is perfectly able to continue
now with e4
black's idea that we're going to look at
is e5 we'll look at the move d5 next
this is the main alternative
e5 and now this does apply enough
pressure here to warrant a response by
white
but we can just play this move a3
black's best response is to play bishop
take c3
and now white is going to be able to
keep control of the d4
square it'd be a bit of a mistake i
think to play d5 because this is sort of
what black wanted out of the opening to
get this knight on d4
now i've reminded myself i should talk
about the move e takes d4
this is a legal option but it does just
lead to an advantage for white
after takes on b4 takes on c3
and takes back on on c3 or even the move
b5 first
this is just going to be a good position
for white the bishop pair this pawn on
d6
is never arriving on the d5 square and
this is just
a clean advantage so much so that no
games actually have have made it to this
point
but so bishop takes c3 instead now we
have good control over here
and black has a comparatively worse
position uh
related to similar structures that we've
seen because the pressure on d4
is not strong enough to prevent the move
of bishop d3 by
white and then we just saw some
development
we saw knight a5 it does not make a
difference if black plays b6 by the way
this was a question i saw in the chat
and then we see this break of f4 coming
quite early on
not with any immediate intentions but
just allowing this knight to develop
behind it to f3 and
then we came here c5 was a nice idea to
open up files and diagonals in front of
this king
and then after takes we see white
capturing on e5 getting the central
majority and a very nice game
from here timothev did mess up a little
bit with uh moves like bishop f4
better was just to bring this rook
anywhere into the game in this rook
anywhere end of the game
really any of these moves would have
been great bishop f4 isn't bad either
though white maintains an advantage
c rook c8 rook ae1 take on e5 take on e5
take on d4 take on d4 take on e5 take on
e5
and now we do just get some
simplifications
but still these very much favor white
with
the safer king control of the open file
and
central control leads to a better minor
piece in the form of the knight on e5
versus the knight on a5 pretty clear to
see which of these knights is superior
the game to continue with queen d6 and
again i don't want to show too much of
this because this
is sort of only tangentially related to
our opening now
but timothev does go on to win this game
using this nice central control
and a little tactic to win a pawn
and now eventually goes on to win this
end game
we don't need to know the details end
games not the focus of this class
okay so that is the idea of knight c6
and e5 and
wow we have someone who's played
timothev in the chat that's exciting
why not take e5 instead of a3
um because this is sort of buying into
black's idea
of controlling some of the dark squares
right now this knight is going to have a
nice outpost
on e5 whereas in our main variation this
knight sort of gets relegated to a5
it does apply pressure to c4 but we've
already seen that that pressure is not
enough to make a difference in white's
play
so this just sort of allows black to
have a a pretty active minor piece
d takes e5 though definitely not the
worst move on the board this is playable
for white
but i do think a3 leads to sort of a
tangible advantage
where d takes e5 allows black at least
to have squares for the pieces
for example this bishop might even end
up on this diagonal
and yeah this position is perfectly fine
now nothing wrong with that
but now let us move on to our second
idea which is what happens if black
plays the move d5 and to do so i'm going
to flip to another game another game
this time between two players known as
michael uliben and sergey tiviakov
uh hopefully i didn't do too badly there
and if you notice the results of this
game
uh ulaban actually did end up losing but
that was after
a pretty enormous advantage out of the
opening so no fault of the f3 nymphs are
there sometimes
you lose chest positions where you are
supposedly better
uh and
my laptop seems to have frozen i'm going
to refresh the page here
and we'll keep going but uh yeah
uh-oh progress is now being made on the
laptop front here
um let's see what we can do here
yeah flip to me for a second let's go
ahead and
exit the page
all right we seem to be recovering on
the laptop front
aw snap aw snap dude all right we're
back
we're back great
uh all right so here's our game knight
f6 and as i was saying
lulubin did go on to lose but had a very
nice advantage out of the opening and i
think it was just strictly winning at
some point
so it is a good model game to follow in
my opinion
we have bishop b4 f3 once again knight
c6
e4 and then black's other idea is to
play
d5 so this idea is in my opinion a
little bit more counter-intuitive
than the move of e5 in combination with
this move
knight to c6 but basically the idea here
is that black is sort of baited white
into playing the move e4
and has done so with a useful waiting
move perhaps more useful than king side
castles in some cases so now
uh black is essentially beating white
into playing the move e5 which white
can and should do in many cases and then
he's going to use this knight to apply a
little bit of pressure to this pawn on
d4 so
it is a similar idea to this move v5
it's still rooted
in attacking the d4 pawn but perhaps a
little bit less
intuitively so so how should white
respond to this well
there's really nothing to fear here as
normal we are actually going to want to
play the move
c takes d5 and now after e takes d5
only now are we going to play the move
e5 notably
it's probably not such a good idea to
try and just continue normal development
something like bishop b5 for example
because now uh okay well for one our
epon is hanging and number two i was
going to say
black is happy to open up the d file to
apply some extra pressure to
the d4 pawn as as well so a lot to look
out for here which is why we should just
play the move e5
now why insert c takes d5 and e takes d5
it seems as though it opens up this
bishop
but the fact of the matter is this
bishop doesn't have too many useful
squares on this diagonal that it's going
to be able to occupy
and more importantly it gives us this
nice central 2v1 advantage
and this opening is really about
building a central advantage for white
and we can can very much do so c takes
d5
additionally if black ever does capture
on c3 we're not
really going to want to be left with
with double pawns there as well so cd5
e5
and e5 is my choice uh
and here the move knight g8 is the move
that should be played
uh and this move was potentially
counterintuitive
but basically knight h5 just leaves this
knight a little bit too stranded after
any normal move such as bishop e3 such
as g3
this knight is just a little bit stuck
over here as we've seen in other lines
with knight h5
and knight g8 is actually not as bad as
it may seem
because this knight is simply headed for
the f5 square where it is going to
work well with the knight on c6
now there are actually a variety of ways
you can play this position
by far the most common is to push
through with f4 or bishop e3
and i think both of these moves are fine
but the the deeper i dug into
it i thought potentially black is just
able to equalize
with pretty standard moves right
bringing the knight out to f5
one way or the other uh and just
applying pressure to this pawn
on d4 potentially even going bishop a5
bishop b6
and really stacking up against d4
just sort of classical compensation that
you see in openings like the caro khan
openings like like the french just the
weakness on d4
but the move that i found is the third
most popular in the move played in this
game
of bishop b5 i think this is a really
great way for white to
uh just seize the advantage straight out
of the opening against this knight c6 d5
idea
black can respond with either knight e7
or bishop d7 i think bishop d7 is a bit
better
against 97 it's really not going to
change our plans we're still just going
to develop out
pretty normally either with knight d2 or
with f4 knight f3
uh so let's just focus on bishop d7
again the ideas really aren't that
different it's just that bishop g7
is a bit more forcing in making white
take this knight off the board
directly rather than being able to lay
things after 97
when the knight would still be pinned
okay
so bishop d7 and now our idea is in fact
actually to just take this knight on c6
off the board and this might be a little
bit uh counter-intuitive
to some of you who have been classically
trained
into thinking this is our good bishop
right this is our great this is our good
bishop it's so good it's such a good
bishop why are we
giving it up well the point here is that
black's play
really revolves around pressuring these
pawns in the center
and if black is unable to do that then
black is simply going to be
going to be worse right we have enough
of this central advantage
that if we can just maintain these
center pawns white is
is going to be better and that's why
we're willing to give up this light
squared bishop for this knight which was
doing a good job
of pressuring our central pawns
the game continues now with bishop take
c6 and
f4 and i think this is just a perfectly
fine way
of developing out for white uh
now uh tibiakov plays the move queen d7
we see knight out to f3 and black now
decides it is time
to snap off this knight on c6 before
going any further
black doesn't necessarily have to do
this right away but it's it's not
necessarily the worst
idea either uh mainly because that
knight was doing a great job
of hampering this bishop and pressuring
d5 itself
once this king gets castled now tibiakov
continues through with bishop
to a4 forcing this queen off of the
square and activating this bishop just a
little bit
we see now queen d2 bishop back to b5
harassing the king a bit and that's why
we see uh ulaban
just bring the king out to f2 instead of
castling and
we've seen this before in the f3 nimzo
and i want to reiterate this is just a
very common way
to quote-unquote castle the king don't
necessarily have to do it
literally by castling f2 is often a safe
enough square
for the king when you have such a
massive dominate domination
in in the center and that's the case
here this game now continues with
black castling queen side once again as
we saw earlier in the knight c6
variation
but after the move a4
bishop a6 and bishop a3 white is
is simply better here once again the
king on f2 is actually going to prove to
be safer than the king on c8
and white is is happy to play on the
queen side of the board
this game continues now with the move h5
and now after bishop c5
there's some awkwardness to answer for
on this queen side
black doesn't really want to play the
move b6 because this is a little bit of
a hook
for white to open things up on the queen
side so we see king b8 instead
now rook h to e1 helps support the
center and
in this position it's going to be rather
tough for black to keep everything under
control
because there are very much two threats
that black needs to be pairing
number one is pressure down the b file
and on the queen side against the black
king and number two are threats of
pushing this e pawn forward with
something like f5
and e6 and because of these two threats
i do think that that white has
a pretty nice position uh in this case
the game though did not continue totally
according to plan we saw rook he8
rig a to b1 king a8 now a5
and so far so good for white i think the
the position is is pretty balanced here
but eventually things do start to slip
uh
as we see after rook b8 net h4 queen g4
right back to f3 uh h3
and i'm sort of super skimming through
these moves because they're not the most
important
but this break of f5 is is what i wanted
to get to uh after this move
white was very much better and was able
to uh to go on
with a winning advantage although they
did not end up winning the game
so that's the key idea i wanted to
highlight there uh the the maneuvering
beforehand
wasn't strictly the the most important
to to remember the exact moves
but white's idea is to push through with
f5
and now eventually push through with
either at either e6 or f6
and a winning advantage once f5 is on
the board it's very very clear
that white is doing very very well in
this game
so how do we get there specifically if
you are curious
well this move knight h4 is one to look
at beginning to gain control of
f5 then we see this knight come back
this queen come to f2 h3 drives the
black queen away
and now f5 is simply very very difficult
for black to stop
and white has a nice edge so questions
about how
we got here questions on this before i
do a quick little review
of what what it was
[Music]
why not wait on capturing on c6 with the
bishop well i think black is actually
making a threat here
um that's that's why we need to uh to do
it right away if you play something like
f4
i think knight takes c5 is going to be a
good tactic here
queen e2 doesn't quite work uh because
this knight is
is actually pinned and we're keeping
everything together
with black just barely that's a good
question though so bishop d7
that's why this move is better than 97
in my opinion
uh because it does force the immediate
captures rather than allowing white to
wait
and maybe change change their mind if
things were to change
uh okay
yeah well well then let me do a quick
review of this idea and then
we will move on to the next so
here we're looking at knight c6 e4 we
talked about e5 when a3 is a good
response for white
now against d5 i'm recommending the main
stuff here
we take on d5 push through with e5 and
against knight g8
i like this idea of bishop b5 to
immediately remove the pressure on the
center
that black snipe is exuding bishop d7 is
the best move
uh because it forces the immediate
captures
due to the threat of knight takes e5 so
we take
bishop takes in this game now f4 allows
this knight to develop out behind the
pawn
uh i should mention that perhaps knight
e2 is is even a better move
with the idea of keeping control of some
of these light squares
uh and just uh taking a more
conservative approach to the position
you can still eventually come through
with f4 and f5
this move also though allows ideas of
stuff like knight g3 so 92 by the way
another great idea perhaps even better
than f4 but f4 is fine for white
queen d7 knight f3 we see captures
captures now
as far as the question should black keep
the bishop pair
i mean sure you can leave this bishop on
b4 but the question is is never going to
be more useful than this knight
attacking the d5
the d5 pawn and i really don't see how
right the center is very blocked
it's not really doing a good job on b6
because we sort of preemptively
got rid of this pressure against our
pawn so i think taking on c3
is very reasonable then we saw this
little maneuvering
king f2 and then our last key idea that
i wanted to highlight
was this idea of pressure on the queen
side combined
with pressure on the king's side with
this break of
f5 okay with all of that
let us move along
uh okay what happens the bishop takes a4
so i i will say a4 isn't really the the
critical move here
uh you don't necessarily need a4
included something like brick b1 is is
perfectly fine as well
but a4 if you are playing the spawn
sacrifice in this case
uh i i don't know if there's anything
immediate maybe queen a2 is good
forcing something awkward like b5 and
then still developing out behind it just
opening up files in front of the king
but yeah like a4 isn't a super critical
move in this position or anything this
isn't the type of thing you need to
memorize
uh just have this idea pressure on the
queen slide on the open files
moves like a4 are quite good and then
also threats of playing the move
f5 once we are more developed
okay let us continue on now uh that's
all i have on knight c6
but i wanted to talk about an idea that
we've seen before
uh specifically what happens after
castles
a3 take take and knight h5 right
so this is sort of the best incarnation
of this knight h5 idea and we talked
about this in the the lecture on king's
side castles
but this move knight h5 does have a
habit of creeping up
in very similar positions but not
identical positions and
those are all just i think strictly
worse versions of the knight h5 idea
but be it through you know accident or
on purpose
players with the black pieces are
sometimes playing night h5 when they
they really shouldn't be so i think it's
worth talking about
so to start with i don't have a game i
just have some analysis i want to share
and this is what happens if black plays
oh boy
all right uh lee chess and my computer
seem to be struggling once again so
we'll give that some time to catch up
here
but as i was going to say we're going to
first analyze what happens if black just
plays knight h5
straight on move four right we're
looking at these strange
uh ideas for black on move four tonight
these strange sidelines that that aren't
played too often
and uh yeah definitely knight h5 on move
four is one of those aw snap something
went wrong
all right but we're back in action now i
don't know why this is so important
but okay don't know why we need to wait
for the page to officially crash
before we can move along but if that's
the way it must be that's the way it
must be so net h5 immediately
why wait why castle first why not just
put the knight on
h5 it's a great question well the answer
is because it doesn't do anything
right we saw that the idea of this net
h5 move
in the line where we castle is that
after a3 here
knight h5 uh now we are first of all
unable to play e4 because queen h4 check
is very strong
and if we prepare it with knight h3
black is in time to stop e4
with the move f5 then for example e4
is met by takes takes and queen h4 check
when again
black is going to be winning so my
remedy to this
in short in that lecture was to play
knight f2 first
then continue with e4 and white has a
perfectly reasonable position for
example d6
e4 was was the main line so what's
different
if black just does it outright right
away plays knight h5 well the answer is
the only differences
are are good for white we still play
knight h3 because e4
still loses to queen h4 check
now again if queen h4 we have the move
g3 or knight f2
either is perfectly fine so f5 has to be
the idea
for black otherwise y plane at h5 and
the difference here
is that f5 doesn't actually stop e4 and
this is why knight h5
isn't uh a common move on move four it's
white needs to be prefaced by
castles so for example now we have not
wasted a tempo with a3 b take c3
that tempo instead has been used on
knight h3 so we're allowed to just play
e4 here
and white is is much better for example
the line that was working previously is
no longer good because we simply go
knight f2
and there's no rook on f8 to immediately
checkmate us
then for example of castles bishop e3
white is
pretty much just winning in this
position uh not much else to say here
this is quite good for white g3 to
follow
bishop g2 for example bishop e2 even
castles this knight looks silly
and white has total control over the
center of the board
so better for black is to just castle
and
try desperately to transpose now worst
case here you can play knight f2
and transpose to what we were talking
about in a previous lecture
this pretty much directly transposes
always if you include a3 and b
takes c3 which you know why not include
that
uh or you can try for a little bit more
with the move uh bishop e2 bishop b2
is is also perfectly fine here for white
and maybe is a better attempt at quote
unquote
refuting black's play uh in this case
uh why is that well now uh previously
where we had to first deal with these
ideas
before we can castle our king now white
is just going to castle immediately
and really really have no problems at
all here
really have no problems at all
okay so for example if f4
the immediate kingside castles is
perfectly fine and if f takes e4
the idea is not going to be to take when
now queen h4 check would be quite strong
but to simply castle and this is going
to be a good sacrifice
now for uh for white just open diagonals
for the bishops and active pieces in the
center of the board
but if this stuff isn't your taste if
you don't want more one more thing to
learn
you can always just play knight f2 here
and this is pretty
much exactly what we've talked about
before for example d6
a3 this is literally the the position
from a previous lecture so that's the
immediate knight h5
but that's not the only position where
knight h5 has been tried
so now i want to take a look at an old
idea
that was perhaps an imperfect version of
the knight h5
idea it hasn't really been seen at the
top level
in the past few years i think the latest
games are actually from 2010
2011 but it did make an appearance in
this game against
one robert james fisher some of you may
know
but it didn't go very well for him so
let's see one more time
a slightly different instance of this
knight h5 idea uh we have d4
and we're gonna take a minute here
once again whenever i switch chapters i
think the the laptop just can't handle
it it just crashes
um so we'll let google chrome crash
crash one more time uh and then we'll
we'll continue on here
what am i sipping on i've got some some
diet ginger ale
diet ginger ale for for some reason i
don't know
good question
ah snap all right and we're back
and we're back knight f6 c4 e6
all right knight c3 bishop e4 f3
and then in this game we're going to
look at the idea appearing after d5
rather than king side castles so we have
a3 take on c3 take on c3
castles take on d5 uh e takes d5
and e3 uh so this is a position we have
looked at before
and of course the main move here is c5
we looked at some some
other ideas for black as well in one of
the
maybe the first lecture where i talked
about the d5 plants
but knight h5 is actually a legal move
here
as well and the point of this move is to
stop white's natural development with
bishop d3 it's just basically aimed at
making
bishop d3 unplayable due to the idea of
queen h4 check now there are a variety
of ways
that white can deal with this the simple
move knight e2
is going to be perfectly fine for white
and maybe we would see something like g4
bishop e2
this bishop g2 this type of developing
plan has been seen before
but i personally like the move queen c2
the best that was played in the game
uh what's the point of this move well
the point of this move is to
parry the threat of queen h4 sort of
with tempo
now white is threatening to play e4
himself in many cases
and queen h4 is no longer going to be a
threat thanks to queen f2
also by not playing knight d2 we still
allow ourselves the option
to play bishop d3 which would not be
playable
if knight e2 were white's choice uh now
though black can continue making
immediate threats with the move rookie 8
this is really the only justification
for knight h5
otherwise white is just going to develop
very very normally
now if bishop d3 there are still some
problems to deal with
for example queen h4 check queen f2
knight f4 is some nasty nasty business
that you don't want to find yourself
uh dealing with of course queen takes
queen so that by knight takes g2
so best for white is to first play this
move g4
now the knight can still come to f4 and
in fact is almost forced to
but white is ready to respond with the
move h4 stopping queen h4 check
from becoming a threat also notably if
queen h4 check here
were to be played now we are happy to do
this because
there's no time to play knight f4
anymore
yeah in knight f4 here of course we can
just take because our bishop still
defends
g2 okay so g4 knight f4
h4 is the idea for white and then after
c5
uh when in doubt play the move king f2
this
forces this knight back off of f4 and
now
after bishop d3 white can continue with
the normal developing plan
that we've seen before just with some
extra space on
on the king's side to boot right let's
see it as a positive here
not weaknesses extra space extra space
for sure um and i kind of do mean that
that seriously
it can be scary with your king looking
so airy but
uh wow i'm i'm rhyming uh but the extra
space is gonna be worth it
and i think this game does very well at
demonstrating it and i'll show you the
rest of the game
uh shortly although actually knight g6
was played in the game
but i went through that pretty fast so
let's take another look uh step by step
knight h5 stops bishop d3 with the queen
h4 track
threat so we go queen c2 parrying
queen h4 with queen f2 black continues
to make threats with
rook to e8 this also effectively stops
bishop
to d3 because queen h4 check with knight
f4 is a strong idea
so white plays g4 to force the knight
away the knight still comes into f4
it comes to f6 we again can just
continue with natural development no
problems here
knight f4 is the only way to continue
posing problems and now we go
h4 to stop queen h4 check ourselves
the game continues with c5 and white
eventually is able to untangle
with the move king f2 forcing the knight
back and allowing
natural development so questions on that
because i think this is where
the the opening sort of starts to fade
and the middle game starts to begin
these immediate problems that black was
posing are no longer going to be
so so scary is this breeziness for the
king a bit
risky for newer players i mean it's uh
like sure anything is a bit risky for
for newer players i would argue
um in this case i would argue that this
is better for newer players than a lot
of openings because i think the problem
that newer players run into
is not necessarily getting checkmated
right away but
not really knowing what to do with their
pieces and as we'll see in this game
it's very clear what white should be
doing with the pieces and i think that
makes up for uh
for the slight weakness of the king
pippin joke has a line he'd like me to
look at bishop d3
queen h4 check king f1 knight g3 check
and you say yay this just isn't good
unfortunately uh rooks are good better
in many cases than knights and i don't
think you're really going to be
comfortable playing e4 here
after take take for example it's just a
little bit too
too breezy right this queen is too
active the king is too weak
black's pieces have squares it's going
to be a little scary
so better is just to play g4
all right now let's see how the game
continues we have king f2 uh black shows
knight g6 in the game knight e6 is also
perfectly fine but it's not going to
change their change very much
knight g6 we see bishop to d3
knight takes h4 isn't really going to be
an option due to bishop takes h7
so knight c6 played in the game and now
simply knight e2
getting developed uh bishop e6
and we do now see white push through
with the move of g5
h5 by the way also a perfectly playable
idea as some people in the chat were
mentioning
but in the game white shows this way to
continue and
probably for good reason because it
seemed to work out well
rook c8 was played in the game uh
notably
black doesn't really have any way to
lock things down on the king's side of
the board
if you touch this h pawn trying
something like h5
i'm just going to snap on g6 and be a
pawn to the good
so rook c8 is what bobby fischer came up
with trying to apply pressure down the c
file but now white just rolls through
black's position with
h5 and g6 to follow and
this is just a tough position for black
fg6 was played hg6
h6 now trying to lock things up but
queen b1
steps off the c file and as i said
it's pretty clear what white is doing
white is attacking on the king's side
black is trying to find some play down
the c file but it's all a little bit
vague and i'm not sure what specific
threats black is actually going to be
able
to to generate on this side of the board
and that can lead to some real practical
difficulties
for black and it was too much for bobby
fischer to handle i'm willing to wager
it's too much
for a lot of class level players to
handle as well
so bobby tried knight a5 which is an
idea that is very natural an idea that
we've seen before
in these f3 nimzo positions uh where
black is just going for it for play on
the queen side of the board
but now white continues with knight f4
and the pressure on the king's side
proves to be
more relevant than the queen side
pressure c4
was bobby fischer's attempt trying to
get a strong stronghold on
b3 maybe it's a better attempt to
keep the option open to open the c file
but
you know black has problems there as
well
namely the fact that you just can't
generate any concrete threat
on this side of the board really so c4
was the attempt followed by rook c6
going for pressure down the b file rook
a2
is a nice move that we've seen before to
bring this rook into the game
now knight d7 tries to reactivate this
knight
a4 once again comes into play this case
with the idea of activating the bishop
on a3
as we see now rook b2 applies pressure
on this side of the board as well
rook b5 and yeah sort of
black is is fighting a battle uh on
three fronts at this point there's a
weakness on d5
there's threats of opening things up on
the queen side with uh
something like a5 there's threats on the
king's side with this pawn on g6
and actually i light it's it's a fight
on four fronts because white's now
playing e4
and and breaking through in the center
right white just has an advantage sort
of on
on every every side of the board uh
tough to argue
with with that and white now is
in fact uh just just strictly winning
knight b7 was perhaps the final mistake
uh the computer likes knight b3 instead
but
this move is is also pretty bad in light
of ideas
uh simply like e4 as well so knight b7
e4
and it's just pretty busted now for um
for black uh white actually takes with
the bishop notably f takes is not really
going to be the idea here
just because it uh perhaps makes a few
too many weaknesses
around this this white king we don't
need to open the f file lose control of
g4 so e4 the idea was to take with the
bishop
and apply pressure down this side of the
board
we see knight takes or we don't see
knight takes e4 but if we did
it would just be replied to by queen
take c4 and
the the same awkwardness sort of
persists here if you try something like
bishop f5 for example
well sorry you can't you can't really
move this bishop uh because i would take
it
and yeah like rookie five is coming it's
it's just all a disaster
so bishop takes c4 rook c to c8 was
played but now
still rookie five and uh at the end of
the day
when the dust settles here we'll see
that bobby fischer
is just getting slaughtered extra bishop
for white and that is enough to win the
game
those tactics once again i did just sort
of flip through them but
pressure on this bishop so bobby tries
bishop g4 but now just knight d5 is
played
take take is an in-between move now we
take here
even material for the moment but what do
you do with this bishop
the answer is you can't do anything with
this bishop to come back here
even this is good enough uh queen c1 to
h6 is good enough
everything is winning so bobby gives up
the bishop instead
and from here goes on to lose the game
because
white has more bishops and bishops are
good
right free queen white is winning
so questions on this game and this
knight h5
idea in particular it's a little bit
different than the previous knight h5
ideas it's not with the intention of
stopping e4 with this f5 move
it's just with the intention of making
development awkward for white
with the move of bishop to d3 no longer
being playable
as we saw if i can flip back bishop d3
losing the queen h4 right and one more
time just review
our idea is to go queen c2 pairing queen
h4 with queen f2
also supporting e4 after rookie 8 the
only move to continue applying pressure
we go g4 to kick the knight away and
eventually
h4 to stop queen h4 and king f2 to force
the knight back
and then we saw that white has an
advantage sort of on every side of the
board
with threats of pushing e4 threats on
the queen side down the b
file and threats on the king's side with
the pawn storm that we saw
in the game so questions on
this one questions here
would i enjoy playing white in this
variation well i think white is
objectively better in this variation so
i tend to like positions where i'm
objectively better
sometimes i like positions where i'm
objectively worse even
but generally i like the ones where i'm
better
uh if c4 for black and the g4 h4 line do
you just take the knight on g6
let's see what we're talking about here
talking about c4
you can do any number of things maybe
you take with the the bishop on g6
and the point now is that you get to
open the h file
you don't necessarily want a piece but i
think this is pretty good
pretty good uh okay
so with that i'm going to attempt to
switch
chapters here on lean chest i'm going to
turn off the computer evaluation
and i'm going to very very gingerly
click next chapter
it worked we didn't freeze okay wait
wait the night is still young and i can
make moves
okay and we're continuing all right life
is good
life is good look at us go all right no
freezing it's a little bit
delayed but i'll trust it knight c3
bishop b4
f3 b6 okay so this is the the last idea
i want to introduce tonight
um it's the idea of basically what if
black decides i was kidding about
playing the nemzo indian i meant to play
a queen's indian defense
and while this is not a very good way to
play i think this is something
you'll sort of run into with some people
playing the nemzo indian
uh why is that well i've talked before
about d5 perhaps being the natural plan
and why i say this is the natural plan
and the plan you run into a lot
is because a lot of players with an mzo
indian they see the move f3
they hit the panic button and they say
all right i don't know what's going on
here i'm just going to play good solid
moves
and speaking from experience as an
amazon indian player myself with the
black pieces
whenever i hit the panic button i tend
to just go back and default to queen's
indian
ideas this sort of setup bring the
bishop to b7 control the center from the
outside
this is like how the queen's indian
works right if i don't know what's going
on in my nimzo lines
i can usually just default to playing
the queen's indian defense
and i think this is the the same
thinking for for some players so it's
worth knowing what to do
if black randomly plays b6 now not a
very good move you're not going to see
this at a very high level of play
uh you know 99 and a half percent of the
time you're just not going to see the
move b6
but i still wanted to talk about it
because you might run into it
practically
in your games so as with any move
that doesn't directly challenge our
center for example
c5 challenges our center d5 challenges
our center
whenever black does not challenge our
center we're going to play the move e4
now black has a variety of things that
they can do
for example castles is the main thing
i'm going to focus on but bishop takes
c3
is something you might see immediately
as well and the idea here is once again
to go for this dark squared plan
sometimes players with the black pieces
just sort of
strong arm their way into it but it's
just going to be
similar to what we looked at i think
actually last lecture but black has
randomly included the move b6 seemingly
for for no reason
so so white should of course be fine
here once again
we see that black has not applied enough
pressure to the d4 pawn
to prevent white's natural setup with
the bishop on d3 and the knight on e2
and for that reason white is a little
bit better here
uh just for example this was some game
between two random people
um named konovalov and mayarov
and meierov from somewhere they weren't
that good at chess
but this is just a reasonable setup for
white that i wanted to highlight
uh okay and white is going to be better
again because of the natural setup
good squares for this knight and
eventually we can think about playing an
f4 break or a c5 break
or an a4 a5 and any of these ideas
are going to be perfectly fine for white
so that's bishop takes c3 if black sort
of stays true to the queen's indian
defense idea
and just castles king's side we have no
fear here just play bishop d3
continue normal development and you will
be better
for example c5 d5 e takes d5 c takes d5
was played in some game
d6 knight e2 uh and this is where i sort
of ended my analysis here this stuff
really doesn't appear too often and i
just wanted to highlight
that this looks very very similar to our
positions that we see after four
c5 with the exception that black has
played
or has wasted an entire tempo playing
the move b6 when oftentimes
this pawn just belongs on b5 so for
those reasons
these are really just going to be worse
versions of stuff we've already looked
at
but i thought it was worth mentioning
this tricky move order
okay so with the last few minutes here
i want to go over perhaps my favorite
game
in the f3 nimzo which is
a little bit of a lie because it's not
even a game in the f3 nemzo
it's a game between uh mikhail botfinik
and jose raul capablanca
from 1938 uh botfin at capablanca avro
1938. it's a great great game
and it doesn't start in the f3 name so
but they they find their way there
eventually so let's take a look here i
think this is sort of the the
quintessential
f3 nimzo game if i had to pick one that
truly embodies the opening i think it
would be
this game which is ironic because it
didn't start in the f3 nimza but anyways
let's just take a look here
we have d4 and we have a nimzo indian
but white starts with e3 we'll see that
after d5
a3 take take we see the move
c5 cd5 ed5 and this should be looking
pretty
familiar here if you insert the moves f3
and kingside castles
then you just have an f3 nimso so it's
just
a different move order to arrive at
stuff we we've already seen white starts
by developing the bishop with bishop
d d3 black castle's king side
sorry excuse me and you could play f3
now and once again transpose
but white just continues delaying it
with knight e2 no reason not to
uh b6 now for black and black is aiming
to trade off the light squared bishops
as discussed i think in lecture number
one
black really should be trying to trade
off these bishops the bishop on d3 is
just always better than the counterpart
on c8
so kingside castles uh bishop a6 we see
bishop takes a6
knight takes a6 uh and then white
continues delaying
the move f3 with the move bishop to b2
so maybe i i am wrong in calling this an
f3 nimzo game
but really you know the the f3 is sort
of implied at this point
white is going to play f3 and push for
e4 and you can tell this
by the move bishop b2 with this move
white is
uh you know sort of
adding support for the d4 pawn the only
reason
you need to do that is if you're
planning to move your e pawn to e4
the only way you're moving your e pawn
to e4 is if you if you play the move f3
so just some move order tricks here but
white is planning to play the move f3
and push forward this game continues
with queen to d7
and now bot venice starts playing some
really nice moves that i think you can
learn learn a lot from here so what are
the ideas
in this structure well we know white's
idea white's idea is to push
f3 and e4 as i keep saying but what is
black's idea how does black
find counter play well we've seen in
previous games that black
tends to take on d4 and try to open the
c file
try to put this knight on c4 this is one
way of achieving counter play
but perhaps the most direct threat is to
go with c4
b5 a5 and b4 right this is sort of
black's most structured way to make
concrete threats on the queen side
so botfinec actually anticipates that in
this case
and inserts the move a4 which i think is
a really great move
to uh to insert here for white now it's
not going to be necessary
in every game in f3 and enzo in this
type of structure
but i think here it is actually quite
nice to play a4
just with the idea of stopping b5
now black continues with rook f to e8
and white plays queen d3
to add some support to the e3 pawn for
the eventual
push through with f3 we see c4 now
by black also by the way white was
pressuring the knight
and so black commits to c4 shutting down
the c file now personally
i think maybe black should have kept the
option open to take on d4
and play the move knight b8 with the
plan of coming out to a5
taking here playing knight c4 i think
this just tends to be
a better way to find counter play for
black because what black does in the
game is simply far too slow
but c4 queen c2 now knight b8
rook ae1 adding support for the e pawn
knight c6 knight g3
knight a5 and now finally i can stop
feeling like a fraud
boffinic plays the move f3 and we are
very much in a f3 nimso position
at this point uh and now in the game
capablanca sort of uh goes goes after
this a pawn
that white spent a tempo on and while
this wins a pawn
uh we'll see that blacks or whites play
in the center
is so powerful that the a pawn is is
just sort of irrelevant
it doesn't matter at all that white lost
the a pawn the only purpose of this a
pawn was to slow down the pawn storm and
it has served that purpose
uh with great effect uh so capablanca
tries knight b3 but now just
a uh just pawn to e4 uh white breaks in
the center
and this is enough to to win the game
queen takes a4
is kappa blanca's idea but now e5 knight
d7
queen f2 it's a nice little subtlety uh
defending the d pawn and preparing to
push through with f4
and now quickly i will show you guys the
rest of the game
uh f4 black plays f5 because really
there's nothing else you can do here
otherwise white's going to play f5 and
just checkmate you
so f5 should be tried now a really key
move here by by white
taking on f6 on passant making sure
we can still open files up on the side
of the board where we have more space
especially when black's pieces are are
stranded over here on the queen side
knight takes f6 continue now with f5
take take
rookie eight rookie six is a great move
by botfinek forcing black to open up
more files if he wants to continue
trading pieces
in this case he does but now the threats
against the king are going to be too
much
king g7 queen f4 threatens to invade
queen e8 queen e5 pins the knight to the
king
queen e7 and then if you guys want to
try and find the move of the game i
would encourage you to pause here
and think for hours and hours and hours
about what the best move is going to be
um but if you just want to see the rest
of the game here it is
last warning pause now if you want to
find it the move of the game
bishop a3 um finally we see this bishop
coming into play and drawing the black
queen
way over back to the queen side and this
is in fact the
the death sentence for black
queen takes a3 is played and the idea
now is knight h5 check
queen g5 check queen takes f6
e7 and queens or
checkmate are unstoppable can't stop
both of these ideas
capablanca does have some checks though
and he does do his due diligence
and plays those checks but white
picks up the pawn on h5 plays g4 and
after king h5
the checks run out and capablanca
resigns
uh so why is this my favorite game in
the quote-unquote f3 names i know it
didn't start in the f3 name so but we
got there eventually well
it shows you the the core problem for
black
in these these most common f3 nimzo
lines and that is
no matter what you're doing on the queen
side white's play in the center is so
severe that unless you are like
literally making a queen
on the queen side unless you literally
break through with b4 and your c pawn is
queening
then you're just gonna get checkmated
like it's just tough you just get
checkmated you can't stop it
and that's why the f3 nimzo is so
powerful and so great in a nutshell is
you just you play e4
and it's just so difficult for black
right if you achieve this move e4
even at the cost of a pawn even at the
cost of some things on the queen side
you just win the game nine times out of
ten you just checkmate black
practically it's impossible to defend
objectively
you know against with perfect play maybe
like black can try
and survive but over the board uh
telling you from experience
you just end up checkmating the guy so
so often
and that's what bob finnick did here
against cappa blanca
if you want a more in-depth review of
that game by the way i do think there is
a game review
on the youtube channel that i've done on
this one where i go a little bit more in
depth
but like i said probably my favorite
game and the f3 names are right there
um that's going to do it that is going
to
uh completely finish our series on the
f3 nimso here
hopefully you guys enjoyed it i had a
lot of fun going through
everything and maybe yeah maybe i'll do
like a
just a recap video where i talk about
everything but i'm not sure that'll be
on chess openings explained i think it's
time we moved on to something new
next week so thank you guys for writing
out this f3 nimzo journey with me
hopefully you guys enjoyed it as much as
i did if you're watching live please
head on over to the twitch channel for
tactics time
for watching the youtube version once
again thank you so much for sticking out
in this eight part series
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
i will see you next time
you